ten years after revenge of the sith
obi-wan kenobi is readying a rematch
with darth vader
[Music]
hello there it's a good time to be a
star wars fan after the one-two punch of
the mandalorian seasons one and two
followed by the book of boba fett disney
isn't letting up it's only a short wait
until may 25th the day obi-wan kenobi
lands on disney plus with the lead role
reprised once more by ewan mcgregor he
will be joined by his former castmates
hayden christiansen who returns as
anakin skywalker now known as darth
vader even more star wars episode 3
revenge of the sith alums are along for
the ride as joel edgerton and bonnie
peace return to their roles as owen and
baru lars luke skywalker's uncle and
aunt it even appears jimmy smits may
return as a senator from alderaan bail
organa
in terms of new faces comedian and
eternal star kameo nanjiani is on board
in a still unknown role game of thrones
alumna indira varma and moses ingram of
the queen's gambit fame had similarly
secretive roles until the new teaser
trailer dropped on march 9th the sneak
peek of the original series reveals
varma is playing an imperial officer and
ingram will be playing the role of riva
an imperial inquisitor with so many
characters from the prequel trilogy
making their return amid so many new
faces many fans have wondered when
exactly obi-wan kenobi takes place and
how it fits into the larger star wars
timeline as it turns out those questions
have quite intriguing answers despite so
much about the show being shrouded in
sith-like secrecy we still know a lot
about where obi-wan kenobi fits into the
history of star wars that's good news
obi-wan kenobi will take place about 10
years after the rise of the empire in
revenge of the sith as confirmed by a
tweet from the official star wars
twitter account from december 2020 to
date the disney plus star wars shows
have primarily focused on the
post-imperial era both the mandalorian
and the book of boba fett are set in the
years after the death of emperor
palpatine in star wars episode 6 return
of the jedi so it will be fascinating to
finally see a story that takes place
during the height of imperial power
based on what we've seen in trailers and
from casting announcements obi-wan
kenobi will follow its titular character
as he watches over a young luke
skywalker and perhaps a young layer from
afar it appears the clone wars general
is being pursued by imperial forces all
the while including several red
lightsaber toting figures who appear to
be imperial inquisitors these are force
sensitive hunters tasked with
exterminating the last of the jedi order
led by the former jedi known now as the
grand inquisitor it appears the empire
is still busy hunting down those who
manage to save themselves after order 66
and will stop at nothing to purge the
galaxy of them obi-wan is sure to be a
major target in their campaign
especially since hayden christensen is
slated to return as darth vader
something tells us he's not going to let
his former master slip off into the twin
sunsets of tatooine so easily i'm
getting too old for this sort of thing
the final act of revenge of the sith
ends with obi-wan kenobi witnessing the
birth of padme amidala's newborn twins
luke and leia after padme dies in
childbirth a decision is made to
separate the twins and keep them in
hiding senator organa and his wife
become the adoptive parents of leia who
will grow up on alderaan meanwhile luke
is destined to grow up on tatooine where
ewan mcgregor's obi-wan kenobi leaves
him in the care of owen and baru lars
star wars episode 4 a new hope takes
place 19 years after revenge of the sith
which means luke and leia are also 19
years old when the original star wars
trilogy kicks off this puts disney plus
limited series obi-wan kenobi almost
smack in the middle of the two films in
regard to the star wars timeline this is
seemingly confirmed by the brief shot of
what appears to be a young luke who
looks to be 9 or 10 years old in the new
teaser trailer
raised by uncle owen and aunt beru luke
is seen through obi-wan's futuristic
binoculars living on their moisture farm
and pretending to pod race this may be a
deliberate call back to star wars
episode 1 of the phantom menace in which
a much younger obi-wan meets a much
younger anakin also a pod racer on that
same sandy planet being set 9 years
before a new hope also means that
obi-wan kenobi happens around the same
time of the events of solo a star wars
story which follows a young han solo
lando carissian and chewbacca it's
unlikely that obi-wan will cross paths
with any of those characters both
because none of the solo actors have
been cast in obi-wan kenobi and because
the jedi in hiding doesn't meet han solo
until the canteen is seen in a new hope
still it's thrilling for fans to finally
see the years between the prequels and
the original trilogy explored in such
depth
always on the move
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]